[Música]
ahora bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta emisión nos
acompañan rodolfo hernández candidato
independiente a la presidencia de
colombia para los comicios del próximo
29 de mayo el es ingeniero civil y fue
alcalde de la ciudad colombiana de
bucaramanga entre el año 2016 y 2019
rodolfo hernández muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en la entrevista de france
24 en español
bueno le agradezco muchísimo al canal de
santiago por la oportunidad que me da de
comunicarme con tan importante medio y
con esa gran audiencia muy amable no
gracias a usted y muy amable de ustedes
de rodolfo comencemos si les parece
hablando de las elecciones legislativas
del pasado 13 de marzo aquí en colombia
unas elecciones en las cuales las
fuerzas de izquierda obtuvieron la mayor
cantidad de votos no para un congreso
históricamente de centroderecha hubo
además un retroceso del partido
oficialista hablamos del centro
democrático que dominó la política
colombiana durante las últimas décadas
qué mensaje cree usted rodolfo que
dieron los colombianos en las urnas
aquella jornada
yo creo que los colombianos como
seguramente en cualquier parte del mundo
ya están cansados en recibir y estar
gobernados por la izquierda o por la
derecha aquí llevamos 20 ó 30 años con
la derecha es decir es un gobierno
totalmente neoliberal los desastres que
nos va a dejar este gobierno son
muchísimos y eso generó tan claro y al
france24
comentarlos que en colombia nos dejaron
22 millones de gentes aguantan one
y
17 millones viven con dos dólares
y cinco columna en una población de 50
millones el 40 y 40 por ciento de la
población sin condiciones extremas de
pobreza total de que un gobierno que ha
tenido la oportunidad tenía walk kansas
ingreso reforma tributaria y eso tiene
que haber una causa y cuál es la causa
la construcción se han dedicado a
saquear el país y cómo tienen control a
justicia lo organismo de control
disciplinario como la procuraría general
de la nación como la fiscalía como la
contraloría general de la república pues
no pues eso no es un juego libre el 29
de mayo que es que queremos interpretar
los sentimientos de los colombianos para
realmente hacer un gobierno que piensen
los colombianos y no en una copa
solamente en la que están lucrándose de
la renta de la nación lo que pasa en
colombia y gravísimo esto ya no resiste
más
esto se necesita corregir en la próxima
gobierno porque ya no hay capacidad de
maniobra para poder seguir los impuestos
y generando más pobreza hasta que pueden
terminar en disturbios totalmente graves
que no le convienen a ningún pueblo
corrupción y pobreza no los desafíos que
sin lugar a dudas marcarán la agenda del
próximo mandatario colombiano haremos
ahora de una encuesta a rodolfo porque
una encuesta del centro nacional de
consultoría al 19 de marzo esta encuesta
marcaba que el candidato de izquierda
gustavo petro estaba liderando lo que es
la intención de voto con el 32% seguido
por federico gutiérrez de derecha con un
23 por ciento y en tercer lugar usted
mismo y también sergio fajardo con una
cifra cercana al 10 por ciento a qué
atribuye usted este posicionamiento en
los 2 además de por supuesto su vasta
trayectoria política cree que se vincula
quizás a su fuerte presencia en las
redes sociales usted mismo se define
como el rey del tick tock y bueno gran
parte de su
bueno en su cuenta de twitter
mire este resultado de petro que
representa la izquierda extrema tiene el
30 o el 28 no importa va ganando y con
suficiente ventaja
el mejor promotor de la campaña de la
izquierda ha sido el mismo presidente
duque no ha hecho absolutamente nada en
beneficio de la ciudadanía y ese es el
resultado como los pobres son el 90 por
ciento de los colombianos ese 90% está
apoyando a petro que les ofrece un cielo
pero sabemos que apenas legend petro si
no le pone orden a las finanzas públicas
el infierno sigue eso no es echando
discursos es asiento cuando esto el
alcalde
j no le fue tan bien esa es la verdad
entonces predicó gutiérrez de segundo
todo el gobierno violando las normas
electorales
tanto de fuego para que federico tenga
que crezca y pueda competir le apretó
pero eso no nos interesa a nosotros al
pueblo colombiano lo que le interesa es
que quien va a ser capaz de hacer lo que
hay que hacer que es parar en seco la
roba de la robadera aquí no la paran
porque esas personas quieren seguir en
la política como son jóvenes quieren
seguir en la política y como quieren
seguir en la política quieren quedar
bien con todos total de posesiones y el
día que se posesione federico gutiérrez
para ser igual indicó que lo que yo dijo
que federico útiles en duke 2
a menudo
quisiera bueno vamos ahora a hablar un
poco de su historia personal bueno
atravesada por la política tris
trágicamente atravesada por lo que ha
sido el conflicto armado verdad rodolfo
la guerrilla del ejército de liberación
nacional secuestró a su hija en el año
2004 si no me equivoco ya permanecía el
día de hoy desaparecida usted encargaría
un acuerdo de paz con el ejército de
liberación nacional esto por un lado y
por otro lado preguntarle cómo evalúa la
implementación de los acuerdos de paz
con la ex guerrilla de las farc
vive con respecto a la tragedia que
sufrió mi familia yo como papá de la
niña eso es terrible saber que su hija
está secuestrada y que su hija nosotros
ya santiago la declaramos desaparecida
ya hemos esperado
18 años yo creo que un tiempo suficiente
con la búsqueda que hemos hecho con la
dedicación a buscar una respuesta de esa
desaparición y no hemos resultó no se ha
resuelto nada hemos declarado todas las
familias en el duelo y empezar los
procesos jurídicos para declarar la
desaparición
yo no sé si se llame forzada lo cierto
es que nosotros ya la damos con todo el
dolor del alma por muerta la violencia
en colombia me la quito
esa es la verdad precisamente para ahora
si se me pregunta santiago sé qué ha
hecho el gobierno nacional para cumplir
con los acuerdos de paz pero ha hecho
nada y si no hacen nada después de
firmar un gobierno el acuerdo de paz la
violencia ya empezó otra vez a activarse
total de que necesitamos un gobierno que
seguramente yo lo voy a presidir
tontería tras todo ese dolor toda esa
tragedia cumplamos los acuerdos de paz
invitemos a todos los que están todavía
afuera de ese acuerdo a firmarlo y
cumplirlo el cumplimiento de ese acuerdo
es con presupuesto si tenemos
presupuesto podemos empezar a esos
guerrilleros de origen agrario ponerlos
a trabajar a producir que ganen platica
para que mejoren las condiciones de vida
de su familia y le aporten la colombia
eso es lo que hay que hacer cumplidos
precisamente a rodolfo así está apuntada
de próxima pregunta no quería hablar de
la violencia en colombia una violencia
que tiene varios frentes por un lado lo
que es el conflicto armado y también lo
que son las violaciones a los derechos
humanos cometidas por las propias
fuerzas de seguridad que están en la
mira de organismos nacionales y también
internacionales esto con más fuerza tras
el estallido social del año pasado que
dejó decenas de personas muertas y hasta
denuncias incluso de abusos sexuales
cometidos por uniformados encargaría
usted una reforma de fondo en las
fuerzas
pues seguramente habrá que tratar eso
pero es que la eso son consecuencias
santiago ya todos los que nos escuchan
en los ven hay que mirar la causa la
causa estaba en torno a la muchachada
sobre todo la que esté estudiando el
nivel superior
mala educación porque nunca tienen
presupuesto suficiente para atender el
profesorado
elemento en politiquería para nombrar
los profesores toda esa acumulación de
necesidades despertó todo lo que usted
se llama la protesta y esa protesta
entonces el gobierno en lugar de
analizar mirar si la muchachada que en
cualquier parte del mundo en francia lo
eeuu en inglaterra en italia en
cualquier país del mundo lo que quiere
lo que también de una buena educación
alta calidad gratuita es ahora lo que
están pidiendo y entonces el gobierno
responde es con violencia y la violencia
genera más violencia con la violencia no
hay nada que hacer hay que negociar
escuchar la gente mirar si tienen
responsabilidades o de resolver el
problema con el fin de que eso se hagan
todas esas secciones que arruinan a
muchos comerciantes que están en la
línea de paso y les queman el negocio
los apedrean se les meten candela y con
esa violencia nos ha cambiado si yo
llego a ganar como al parecer va a ser
la presidencia de la república yo me
encargo realmente de escuchar a la
muchachada y solucionar los problemas
eso es lo que necesitan los muchachos
rodolfo hernández muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en la entrevista de france
24 se pasó rapidísimo el tiempo pero
tengo que ir despidiendo los
ensayos y al santiago y a todos los los
televidentes muchísimas gracias por la
atención muy amable y un feliz día para
todos gracias lo mismo para usted y a
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a que siga informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y también
por supuesto en france24 punto com sigan
con nosotros
[Música]